we're bringing up the holographic
schematics and outlining how Tony Stark
goes from a genius weapons designer with
no hearts to Iron Man a self-sacrificing
superhero with the heart of gold this is
the entire Iron Man MCU timeline finally
explain consider it all the proof you
need that Tony Stark has a heart so
let's get down to brass tacks shall we
Tony Stark basically comes out of the
womb a genius at age four he builds a
circuit board at age six he builds a v8
engine by 17 years old he graduates
summa [ __ ] laude at MIT and seems poised
to take over Stark Industries whenever
his genius father Howard feels ready to
pass the buck and fortunately after
Howard's assassination in 1991 by a
brainwashed Bucky Barnes who was working
as a Winter Soldier his partner Obadiah
Stane takes over Stark Industries until
Tony turns 21 and takes back his company
from there it's a wild ride of building
new technology and weapons for the
American military for the next decade
while ticking off just about everyone in
the scientific community when the
viewers officially meet Tony Stark in
2008 syam man he's had a weapons
exhibition in Afghanistan to showcase
the Jericho a missile system that uses
repulsor technology to increase
effectiveness for your consideration
[Music]
the jerk on the way back from a
successful presentation Tony is
kidnapped by a terrorist organization
known as the ten rings that wants him to
fill them their own Jericho missile the
explosive kidnapping leaves Tony with
some shrapnel buried near his hearts
caps temporarily at bay with the use of
an electromagnet powered by a car
battery
with his fellow captive ho yinsen Tony
upgrades the electromagnet in his chest
into an arc reactor to keep his heart
safe then he builds his first suit of
armor than Marquand a clunky mobile suit
packed for the weaponry which he Don's
to escape the 10 ranks
sadly ho yinsen doesn't survive the
escape with his dying breath he begs
Tony to do something important with his
life
don't waste a night
nothing like a near-death experience and
the tragic passing of a dude who saved
your life to really shake up your core
principles huh effective immediately I
am shutting down the weapons
manufacturers it is obadiah's against
the decision and so is tony's best
friend Colonel James Rhodey Rhodes
unfortunately Tony's new conscience
comes with the cost the board of Stark
Industries basically alse Tony and it
turns out that Obadiah has been playing
both sides both in terms of the Stark
Industries Board and the global weapons
market he actually led the boar's
betrayal and he's been selling Stark
Industries segued to terrorist groups
the whole time without actual control
over Stark Industries and knowing that
plenty of his tech is already out in the
world
Tony appraises Iron Man suit to be
sleeker and more colorful and embarks on
a quest to take down any terrorist
groups using his weapons after a
successful mission Tony makes a plan
with his secretary Pepper Potts to hack
into Stark Industries and find out what
the rest of his weapons have gone
however Obadiah incapacitates Tony
steals the arc reactor in his chest and
places it in a suit of his own design as
inspired by Tony's first one only his is
bigger a lot bigger
Tony replaces as missing arc reactor
with a prototype that is safe in the
desert and seats up to battle against
obadiah's Iron Monger he defeats Obadiah
with some help from pepper of course
saves a day and then announces to the
world that there's no secret identity
needed I am Iron Man
while Tony's on stage admitting that he
really is Iron Man half a world away
Anton Vanko passes away after telling
his son Ivonne that Tony's life should
have been his Ivonne users are no
blueprint of the arc reactor designed by
his father and Howard Stark in order to
build a replica of the super battery
six months later Tony's turned his
newfound superhero celebrity into an
excuse to bring back the stark Expo as
well as take credit for basically every
good thing that's happened in America
since iron man appeared predictably Tony
subpoenaed to appear in front of
Congress to defend his right to bear the
world's biggest armory he was actually
the well-being priority to get the Iron
Man weapon turned over to the people of
the United States of America
you can forget it Tony talks his way out
but he learns that just in hammer and
hammer industries are trying to fill the
void left by Stark Industries after they
left the weapons game which includes
trying to copy the Iron Man suit and
failing pretty spectacularly meanwhile
Tory's got problems of his own he's
suffering from palladium poisoning from
the continued use of his arc reactor
Tony names Pepper the new CEO of Stark
Industries while Ivonne finishes his arc
reactor powered whiplash outfit Ivonne
attacks Tony during a race at Monaco but
Tony is able to suit up and defeat him
Justin Hammer gets Ivonne out of jail
and a to agree to team up to take down
Tony Stark and Stark Industries you need
my resources someone behind you
benefactor I'd like to be that guy
suffering from palladium poisoning and
flushed from his victory over whiplash
Tony goes off the deep end during his
birthday party he puts on the Ironman
suit as a party trick and starts
blasting away only for Rhodey he's
looking a teensy bit different this time
around to show up in another one of
Tony's suits to try and stop him get out
Tony and Rhodey battle it out to a draw
and Rhodey flies off to give the war
machine suit to the US military hammer
gets the job of outfitting it with new
weapons more Nick Fury the head of
shield gives Tony a firm talking-to
about how he needs to grow up and figure
out how to fix his palladium poisoning
after viewing a heartfelt recording from
its father Tony figures out that Howard
had designed a replacement for palladium
in the 70s but lacking the technology to
build the new elements he buried the
design in the schematics for the stark
Expo what is and always will be my
greatest creation
is you Tony discovers their two bills
the new element and the grades has suit
just in time to interrupt Yvonne's
master plan he's built a fleet of Iron
Man esque drones for hammer industries
that only he controls as well as remote
control over roadies war machine armor
with the help of happy Hogan a Natasha
Romanov who had been working undercover
at Stark Industries under the name
Natasha rushman Tony frees roadie from
Yvonne's control and the two of them
defeat whiplash together but the day
saved roadie keeps the war machine armor
all Tony accepts her role as a
consultants for the Avengers initiative
from Nick Fury Tony Nicks appears in the
post-credits scene for 2080 Incredible
Hulk which takes place around the same
time as the events of Iron Man 2 telling
general Thaddeus Russ that a team is
being put together that team is the
Avengers which Tony officially joins in
2012 see Avengers after Loki steals a
tesseract from project Pegasus Tony
teams up with Captain America and Black
Widow to capture Loki in Germany after
the team naps Loki Thor shows up to
scuffle with cap and Iron Man before
agreeing to team up against whatever
Loki is plotting the team heads to the
shield Helicarrier where Tony and Bruce
Banner aka The Hulk get to work
analyzing Loki's mind controlling
scepter
Loki's henchmen including a hypnotized
Hawkeye ambushed the Helicarrier freeing
the tricks to guard and sending the
Avengers team into disarray the team
comes back together just in time for a
massive battle in New York centered
around stark tower where Loki's
attempting to open a rift to bring in an
invading force of alien Chitauri
warriors
The Avengers stem the tide the world
security council launches a nuclear
missile and the Iron Man drags a missile
through the wormhole into the Chitauri
fleet
seemingly sacrificing his life to
destroy the invaders luckily he's
totally fine kinder in Iron Man 3 which
takes place six months after the
Avengers has revealed that Tony Stark is
definitely not fine he's nearly crippled
with anxiety following his excursion
through the wormhole in the Battle of
New York in the meantime he's dealt with
his manic energy by investing in damage
control an organization originally
created by shield to store dangerous
artifacts and spending his free time
building dozens of Iron Man suits in
case he ever needs more firepower for a
future earth-shattering crisis what
obvious crisis that doesn't take long to
pop up as a Mandarin a mysterious
terrorist leader who's been supposedly
instigating bombings throughout the
world
Who I am
you don't know where I am
[Music]
and you'll never see me coming
after happy hogan is injured in one of
mandarins bombings Tony Khalsa Mandarin
else which leads to Tony's house getting
blown up
Tony flees to Tennessee where he meets
Holly kena a young boy with the gift for
engineering together with Holly
Tony fixes up his suit and learns what a
Mandarin is hiding unfortunately there's
a bigger game at work the Mandarin is
just an actor playing a part designed by
Aldrich Killian and Maya Hansen to give
a narrative for their failed extremist
tests after an raveling a conspiracy
involving the vice president and
Killians plot to kill the president
Tony Rhodey and pepper are able to
defeat Killian and save the day Tony
undergoes heart surgery so he no longer
needs the arc reactor in order to live
and seemingly retires from the hero
business Yeah right Tony Stark doesn't
actually end up retiring since he's
right back in the Avengers lineup in
2015's Avengers age of Ultron on the
hunt for Hydra leader Baron Strucker
Ironman flies in to the castle where
he's hiding and gets Minds doubts by one
the Maxima one of two super-powered
siblings groomed by Strucker for his
evil plans while in the one dispel Tony
sees a vision of his fellow Avengers
dead and the Chitauri army headed for
Earth once he wakes up Tony does what he
always does when confronted with a
possibly terrible future he builds a
suit of armor this time however it's not
a literal suit instead a Tony wants to
build quote a suit of armor around the
world which is basically an artificial
intelligence that can protect Earth from
anything
Tony improves cracked the code on making
it and together they create the AI
dubbed Ultron with the help of the mind
stone and Loki's scepter yeah that's
when everything pretty much falls apart
who sent you Ultron in the flesh
determining that human beings their
problem of the earth Ultron tries to
destroy the world with the help of the
structure children wander and Pietro the
Avengers show up to stop him of course
but wanderin leash is another one of her
telepathic attacks against nearly the
entire team which leads to the Hulk
going on a rampage that only Tony and
his Hulkbuster ama can stop after that
it all comes to a head in the fictional
country of sokovia as Tony builds vision
yet another artificial intelligence
using the mine stone and his Jarvis
program as a personality matrix together
the Avengers and vision save the day
Ultron is blown up and Tony quits the
team at the end of the film I will miss
you too
yeah well time for me to tap out all the
Avengers are doing their business
Tony's trying to cultivate a new breed
of entrepreneurs by paying off the
tuition fees of every single MIT student
in 2016 s Captain America Civil War his
generosity comes under a dark cloud
though when he runs into Miriam the
mother of a young man who died in
sokovia joined the Ultron event his name
was Charlie Spencer you murdered him
inter-korea she reads tell you the riot
act about his lack of responsibility
when general rust later shows up to
suggest that the avengers can under the
official purview of the united nations
tony supporter steve rogers however is
very much against a sokovia accords and
the two men struggle to reconcile the
differences Bucky the Winter Soldier is
freed from custody by helmet Zemo as
part of an extremely complicated plan to
avenge the death of zimos and family in
sokovia Steve gathers a team to help
Bucky evade capture
while Tony gets his own team together
consisting of Black Widow war machine
vision black panther and spider-man a
scuffle with Steve's team at the airport
and serious when war machine is crippled
by an errant blast from vision which
sends Tony into serious mode he arrests
Steve's team - Bucky and cap who have
escaped and pursues cap and Bucky to
Siberia alone dimos plan comes to a head
when Tony discovers that his parents
actually died at Bucky's hand rather
than in a car accident after a brutal
battle cap and Bucky escape - cap shield
but cap gives Tony a cell phone with his
number on it if a time comes that they
ever need to reunite against the greater
threat spoiler alert they will two
months after the events of Captain
America Civil War Tony's biggest
headache is fending off Peter Parker's
desire for his mentorship Peter's
increasingly desperate to get Tony's
attention once a young gay hero
discovers at the vulture a weapons
dealing supervillain has been selling
high-tech weaponry he scavenge from the
wreckage of the Chitauri invasion I am
man Bale spider-man out Twice first with
the help of a remote-controlled drone
and the second time in person trying to
convince Peter to slow down and be a
local hero
before looking to join the Avengers
after the second time when Iron Man's
intervention is the only thing that
keeps this an island ferry from sinking
Tony confiscates the high-tech suit had
given Peter I just want to don't be like
you and I wanted you to be better
okay it's not working out I'm gonna need
the chute back even without the suit
Peter can't help but be a hero and he
ultimately stops the vulture from
stealing a shipment of stark tech as a
reward Tony gives Peter the offer has
been begging for a chance to join the
Avengers and get a brand-new iron suit
when you're ready might you try that on
and I'll introduce the world
the newest official member of the
Avengers spider-man Pizza surprisingly
turns him down and Tony looking for a
way to distract the reporters from an
announcement that suddenly no longer
happening proposes to pepper pods when
Avengers infinity war begins a Tony is
happily married to pepper and having
dreams about their child their
touchy-feely small talk is interrupted
when Doctor Strange arrives to request
Tony's help and repelling the invasion
of thoses black order he would have come
to earth in search of the Infinity
stones that that hose needs to wipe out
half of the universe
gudren bearish me from the Wizards
strange in his time Sona kidnapped by
Thanos his henchmen every more Tony
Stark and spider-man newly decked out in
his iron spider outfits hitch a ride a
more spaceship after freeing strange and
blasting more into space Tony Peter and
dr. strange head to the planet Titan to
prep for Thanos his pursuit there they
went into guardians of the galaxy
members Peter quill tracks mantas and
nebula a plan is hatched and then Thanos
arrives to turn that careful plan into
ashes
with the rest of his allies town Tony
uses a full force of his nanotechnology
powered suit to draw a single drop of
blood from Thanos before the mad Titan
stabbed him through the abdomen with
Tony's own sword dr. strange gives up
the time stone to save Tony's life
leaving Thanos to quickly complete his
Infinity Gauntlet and snap half the
universe into non-existence
Tony survives but Peter Parker turns to
dust in his arms and only he and nebula
are left alive on Titan seemingly with
no way home after Thanos says
devastating victory nebula and Tony
leave Titan in close ship but they don't
have the supply to the fuel to actually
make it all the way back to earth Carol
Danvers aka Captain Marvel intercepts s
ship and gives him a lift home once he
arrives Tony realizes that his 5050 odds
of everyone in his life surviving came
up pretty well
pepper happy and Rhodey all survives a
snap for the next five years the only
thing on Tony's mind is building a life
for himself pepper and a young daughter
Morgan as Tony finally manages to retire
the way he kept promising he would or at
least he retires until Scott Lang
reappears from the quantum realm with a
theory that they could go back in time
and save everyone who died because of
Thun owes what if there was a way that
we could enter the quantum realm at a
certain point in time but then exit the
quantum realm at another point in time
like before Thanos after some hemming
and hawing Tony builds a working time
machine model rejoins the Avengers
returns cap shield and organizes a
strike team of the surviving Avengers to
go back in time to retrieve the Infinity
stones and build a new gauntlet before
Fellowes destroys them in the present
the mission goes smoothly and Tony even
gets a chance of a heart-to-heart with
his dad in the past
everything's gonna be all right thank
you
from there all it takes is one snap of
Hulk's mighty fingers to bring everyone
back however a past version of Thanos
battles has weights the future and only
Tony Stark by sacrificing his life to
use a new Infinity Gauntlet can finally
get rid of him
Tony Stark gives his life to erase
Santos in his world conquering army from
the past finally making good on ho
yinsen x' plea that he not waste his own
life he dies and both of the MCU lives
on
but just because Tony suk dies doesn't
mean that his story dies with him
Tony leaves three extremely qualified
members of the next generation to
succeed him his daughter Morgan Stark
takes after him in a number of ways and
a genius-level intellect seems to run in
the family his young mentee Peter Parker
grew up with a hero worship of Tony
Stark and spends most of spider-man far
from home trying to live up to the
legend of Iron Man
finally Holly keener the young boy that
Tony related to a 9-month 3 appears at
Tony's funeral signifying that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe hasn't
forgotten Tony's first young protege
even before the next generation is able
to take on the weight of the legacy he
leaves some Rhodey and pepper both have
hi-tech battle suits and the knack for
doing the right thing just because Tony
Stark has passed into the great beyond
doesn't mean that the legacy of Iron Man
won't continue to reverberate throughout
the MCU going forward and remember
there's no need to cry for Tony
he knew the hero gig renews tuned check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and at the Bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
you
[Applause]